bonsoir merci nous avoir rejoints pour
cette nouvelle édition du circuit le
journal tout de suite les titres de ce
soir après les urgentistes ce lundi ce
sont les médecins généralistes et les
spécialistes qui leur emboîtent le pas
pour un mouvement de grève dans le
collimateur des médecins certains
éléments du projet de loi santé de
marisol touraine le point avec des
médecins de montigny le bretonneux une
nouvelle campagne de prévention routière
en cette fin d'année je m'engage à
rentrer en vie nous en parlons dans
quelques instants avec mon invité jean
yves petit les grands froids ne sont pas
encore arrivés mais les bénévoles de la
croix-rouge s'activent tous les soirs
pour assurer des maraudes et des
tournées où ils vont à la rencontre de
ceux qui vivent dans la rue nous les
avons suivis aujourd'hui je vous le
disais dans les titres les médecins
généralistes et libéraux ont lancé un
appel à la grève et ce pendant toutes
les vacances de noël ils manifestent
ainsi leur opposition au projet de loi
de santé de la ministre marisol touraine
le point à 50 ans line avec klorane
parfait et william l
si dans les prochains jours vous tentez
de prendre rendez vous avec un médecin
généraliste
il ya de grandes chances que vous
entendiez ceci
était le cas
à la maison médicale de garde de
montigny le bretonneux les 29 médecins
ont voté eux aussi la grève jusqu'au 31
décembre ils protestent contre un texte
de loi qu'il juge inadapté cette loi ne
nous convient pas parce qu'elle nous
augmente les charges administratives au
lieu de les diminuer et puis parce
qu'elle n'a pas de mesures intéressantes
pour recentrer sur le les soins de base
à la population centrée sur le patient
beaucoup de choses avaient été négociées
en amont cette loi n'en contient
pratiquement plus
il faut qu'elle soit revu de fond en
comble ses médecins se relaie ici le
dimanche une partie du samedi et tous
les soirs de 20h à minuit pour eux le
surplus de charges administratives vie
au projet de loi pose un vrai problème
et décourage les jeunes médecins dans
l'installation ou la reprise d'un
cabinet médical comme partout en france
ils sont très concernés par la
désertification
c'est déjà le cas sur le sur notre quoi
nous sur montigny on a à partir du 1er
avril
quatre médecins la première ville 2015
et déjà à partir du 1er janvier 2000
cale depuis quatre médecins qui vont
s'en aller dans le seul quartier de la
sourde oreille à montigny il est pour
l'instant pas d'actualité qu'il soit
remplacé pendant les vacances de noël
les patients pourront se rendre à la
maison médicale de garde la préfecture a
réquisitionné plusieurs médecins afin
qu'une permanence soit assurée les
professionnels espèrent la refonte du
texte avant son passage devant le
parlement d'ici le printemps 2015
et puis ne vous en parlions hier les
médecins urgentistes étaient en grève et
devait donc se réunir ce mardi matin
pour décider ou non la poursuite de leur
mouvement l association des médecins
urgentistes de france amuf a levé son
préavis de grève l'amuf a salué l'accord
historique trouvé avec le gouvernement
sur le temps de travail le plancher des
39 ans a en effet été reconnues on va
changer de sujet on va parler sécurité
routière avec vous jean yves petit
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur comme du
comité yvelines de la prévention
routière et le comité et vince associe
en cette fin d'année une campagne
intitulée rentrer en vie c'est ce qu'on
espère tous pour tout le monde en vérité
en quoi consiste cette campagne alors
c'est la sixième année consécutive que
nous voulons cette campagne avec notre
partenaire assureurs prévention cette
campagne se
se passe en trois phases il y a eu le 13
décembre une
nos bénévoles sont allés au devant de la
population dans une centaine plus de 120
villes de france 4 dans les yvelines
pour leur distribuer éthylotests et
flyers et en leur rappelant l'importance
de prévoir le retour après les réveillon
du 31 décembre essentiellement
il y a également une une phase par par
la presse et les médias un petit film de
30 secondes qui est diffusée sur les
réseaux internet sur certaines
télévisions qui nous offre des créneaux
gratuitement et enfin tout ça se
terminera le 31 décembre par un
événement place de la république comme
l'année dernière l'évènement sera
différent évidemment mais c'était déjà
l'année dernière place de la république
à on comprend l'accent est mis sur la
lutte contre l'alcool au volant vous
l'avez dit l'opération dure depuis six
ans quel bilan on peut tirer en six ans
à septembre alors le le bilan je pense
sur le sur le nombre d'accidents et le
nombre de tués j'ai pas les chiffres en
tête mais de toute façon ça a baissé
depuis six ans c'est incontestable mais
ce qui au delà de ça ce qui est
important c'est que nos concitoyens et
surtout les jeunes prennent conscience
que selon vieux slogan qui datent pas
d'hier boire ou conduire il faut choisir
et à l'occasion du réveillon du 31 c'est
vraiment d'actualité donc c'est toujours
important de sensibiliser à cette
thématique on a l'impression que c'est
quand même rentrer dans la tête de tout
le monde que c'est dangereux de bois et
de conduire après et oui mais vous savez
bien que le l'alcool reste la première
cause d'accidents mortels sur la route
en france je voudrais justement revenir
sur une enquête des associations
prévention routière et assureurs
prévention une enquête menée auprès des
français de 18 à 64 ans sur leurs
habitudes de consommation et parmi les
personnes interviewées 79% des français
déclarent sortir une fois par mois ça
c'est très bien mais par contre parmi
ces personnes à 83 % disent consommer de
l'alcool moi je trouve 83% ça me paraît
énorme
je ne sais pas si c'est donc tout dépend
de la dépend de la consommation de tout
dépend de ce qu'on de ce qu'on consomme
si on abuse ou si on abuse pas et une
fois de plus ce qui est important c'est
de penser à après comment rentrer tombe
chez soi parler de l'après parce que
toujours d'après ce sondage les français
craignent les accidents provoqués par un
conducteur en état d'ivresse tout
particulièrement lors de la soirée de la
saint sylvestre à ce que cette cette
soirée du 31 décembre est vraiment là la
soirée
oui c'est un peu la soirée de tous les
dangers c'est certainement pas la seule
dans l'année mais c'est la soirée en
tout cas qui focalise tous les efforts
des uns et les autres et des
associations telles que la nôtre et qui
focalise peut être aussi les craintes de
nos concitoyens je le conçois mais
globalement avec
l'accent qui est mis sur cette soirée
j'espère que cette année encore ça va
bien se passer comme dans le département
l'année dernière où on n'a pas eu de on
n'a pas eu d'accident gravissime alors
vous dites l'important c'est de bien
rentrer en vie donc de savoir rentrer ce
soit quels sont les bons comportements à
adopter ce qu'il faut d'office choisir
un capitaine de soirée celui alors on
boira pas alors ce qu'il faut avoir les
tests dans sa voiture no
les téléspectateurs pourront aller voir
le site internet rentrer en vie un
www.rentrerenvie.fr dans lequel nous
décrivons ce que nous avons identifiés
comme moyens nous en avons identifié
quatre premièrement dormir sur place
c'est à vrai dire le plus sûr
deuxièmement désigner un sam un
capitaine de soirée tout le monde
connaît je pense le capitaine de soirée
troisièmement commander un taxi et
rentrer en taxi quatrièmement rentrée
avec les transports en commun qui la
nuit de la saint sylvestre au moins dans
les regarde sur les yann sont gratuits
et circulent toute la nuit en
ile-de-france est important de préciser
que les transports en commun seront
gratuits la nuit du 30 et circuler toute
la nuit et toute la nuit donc voilà il
ya pas de raison de ne pas les utiliser
nous sommes allés dans les rues de saint
quentin pour demander aux habitants
qu'elle était justement les dangers sur
la route on va voir s'il évoque toujours
la problématique de l'alcool au volant
abba l'alcool et puis la drogue puis bon
le l'inattention mais je sais plus si la
drogue la drogue est là et l'alcool je
pense que c'est le téléphone au volant a
le téléphone portable sans hésitation
moi mon avis c'est ce qui vous doublent
n'importe quand n'importe comment c'est
à dire la plupart du temps c'est les
jeunes quoi la vitesse l'alcool
l'inattention pour moi c'est les
cyclistes qui roulent pas sur les pistes
cyclables et qui brûlent enfin au feu
rouge et tous à la vitesse d'un petit
patelin où je suis on a eu des
accélérations à l'entrée du village a
été mesurée par un radar à 114 km heure
quand même pas
mal on connaît pas le nom du patelin de
la dame donc on a entendu la vitesse
entendu des cycles je sais pas s'il est
si sûr si dangereux que ça peut-être
quand ils déboitent au feu rouge mais en
tout cas l'alcool et la drogue c'est ce
qu' on revient le plus souvent là les
les personnes interrogées ont
on citer toutes les principales causes
d'accidents un alcool vitesse qui sont
les premières causes d'accidents mortels
la drogue l'inattention causés
essentiellement par le téléphone
on aurait pu ajouter le non respect du
code de la route les refus de priorité
tout ce qui est grillé un feu rouge
grillé un stop faire une queue de
poisson et c est une cause majeure
d'accidents mortels sur la route il ya
deux projets encore mis en place en tout
cas les deux projets on parlait un
moment de réduire la vitesse sur les
départementales de 90 à 80 km/heure
est-ce que 10 km horse a suffi malgré
tout à réduire le nombre d'accidents
alors moi je serais favorable cette
mesure si le gouvernement arrive à nous
prouver que la plupart des accidents ont
lieu dans la tranche 80 90 km parce que
si les accidents ont lieu à 120
kilomètres/heure ou comme la dame le
disais à 114 km heure c'est pas en
réduisant de 10 km heure que ça changera
quelque chose donc moi je ne serais
favorable à cette mesure que si le
gouvernement les pouvoirs publics nous
prouve bien que c'est dans cette tranche
80 90 km heure qui est le plus
d'accidents sinon ça sert à rien par une
autre mesure aussi qui est en projet
mais vous serez peut-être totalement
d'accord j'arrive petit c'est la
réduction du taux d'alcool tournée pour
les jeunes dans le sens pour les jeunes
oui c'est quelque chose dont pas trahir
les héros du mans 0-2 qui qui qui est un
peu dans l'est dans les cartons du
gouvernement
de passer le taux d'alcool pour les
jeunes conducteurs de 0,5 gramme par
litre à 0 2 g par litre comme ça se fait
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
à vrai dire tout ce qui permettra
aux jeunes de prendre conscience que
comme je disais il ya un instant boire
ou conduire il faut choisir tout ça va
dans le bon sens maintenant il faudra
quand même être raisonnable et adapter
les sanctions on pourra pas sanctionner
quelqu'un qui est pris avec 0,3 gramme
d'alcool par litre de sang comme on
sanctionne quelqu'un qui en a zéro 5 on
pourra pas lui retirer six points de
permis ça serait quand même un peu
impossible les chiffres des accidents
sur la route en 2014 sont pas encore
connus forcément la fin de l'année pas
terminé mais ne devrait pas être très
bon en tout cas en france non ils sont
ils sont les raisons ils sont alors ils
sont annoncés comme mauvais on s'attend
à ce qui est environ 5 % à peu près 5 %
d'accidents pour moi c'est la cua
relâchement les habitudes et
comportements
il y a quand même dans le département
j'ai noté quatre accidents dramatiques
qui auraient pu être évitées fin mortel
qui aurait pu être évitée les victimes
ne portaient pas la ceinture de sécurité
ou ne portait pas de casque pour les
deux roues c'est quand même pas pareil
ce nom c'est quand même étonnant les
mais j'étais sous le casque pour les
deux j'étais moi même surpris c'est
quand même on pourrait penser que ce
type d'accident on n'arrive plus à cette
année il y en a eu quatre dans le
département mais pour revenir à votre
question à mon avis la majorité de nos
concitoyens conduisent comme l'année
précédente ils sont pas devenus plus
mauvais tout d'un coup mais on a eu on a
on a eu une météo exceptionnelle pendant
cette année 2014 a été la plus chaude de
tous les temps si je me souviens bien et
en particulier dans notre département il
n'y a pas eu de neige n'y a pas eu de
gel
donc il ya eu plein de boîtes fermées
d'accord à l'un des voitures sont pas
restés au garage les voitures sont pas
restés au garage non seulement les
voitures mais les cyclistes et les
piétons et la recrudescence d'accidents
mortels c'est beaucoup chez les piétons
et les cyclistes il ya eu plus de gens
sur la voie publique donc
malheureusement plus de risque
statistiquement d'avoir des accidents un
autre élément aussi me semble-t-il c'est
l'essence qui n'a pas augmenté et qu'ils
avaient même fortement baissé ces
derniers temps ça non plus ça n'incite
pas les gens à laisser la voiture au
garage donc plus de monde sur les routes
donc plus d'accidents en tout cas il
faut dire que dans les yvelines en 2014
à à l'heure où on parle là on sent 23
décembre ya eu 46 tués sur les routes
d'eysines et celle même si vous nous en
sommes intéressantes de moins au même
chiffre qu'en 2013 donc il n'ya pas lieu
de s'en féliciter à vrai dire c'est pas
mieux pas lieu de s'inquiéter a les
moyens côté positif faut plutôt moi je
vois plutôt dans le bon sens quand les
commandes accidents diminue et là ils ne
diminuent pas merci en tout cas j'en ai
fait il est devenu sur mercialys a envie
de 7,8 le journal je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année puis
alors soyez prudents sur les routes on
va tâcher
aussi par les téléspectateurs
on va parler solidarité maintenant
depuis 150 ans des hommes et des femmes
s'engagent à la croix rouge en haut en
leur temps et leur énergie pour venir en
aide aux nécessiteux sur saint quentin
en yvelines une centaine de bénévoles
s'active et se relaient chaque semaine
pour porter assistance aux populations
en difficulté dans le secteur mélanie
poker williams elles ont passé une
soirée en leur compagnie durant une
maraude
entend pas parler des bougeoirs et de
l'eau bouillante pour pouvoir comparer
des sous des boissons chaudes des soupes
des boissons chaudes
19h45 michel bernard s'occupe des
derniers préparatifs pour venir en aide
aux sans abri avec son équipe ce
bénévole de la croix-rouge rassemble
tous les éléments nécessaires à leur
soirée de maraude
on emmène des sous vêtements des
écharpes
quelques vêtements mais on n'est pas
très riche en vêtements d'enfants c'est
très difficile à transporter parce qu
il est maintenant 20 heures heure du
départ michel appelle le service de
régulation pour connaître les
éventuelles six allemands dans leur
secteur bonjour je rappelle pour savoir
sur la démission
à plaisir d'accord un homme a signalé la
présence d'une personne qui hier dans la
rue michel note l'adresse et son équipe
se met en route immédiatement
ça suscite beaucoup d'émotion je pense
faire ce genre de mission parce que on
tombe sur la mais confrontés à la misère
et quelquefois on a une très très grande
misère
il faut gérer je dirais
mentionné lmnp et psychologiquement
arrivés sur les lieux les bénévoles se
met à la recherche de cette personne
vouloir chercher des personnes ne pas
trouver parce que les gens sont partis
après quelques minutes de recherche un
homme vient à leur rencontre
c'est lui qui a passé l'appel il va les
guider jusqu'au hall d'un immeuble
jean monsieur
croix rouge
appelée comment monsieur
josé abondamment d'accord l'homme semble
déboussolée et a du mal à se faire
comprendre
michel lui propose de l'emmener dans un
centre d'hébergement où il pourra passer
la nuit au chaud après des négociations
il accepte de se faire prendre en charge
par un bonbon lieux des problèmes
familiaux voilà il est à la rue donc ce
qu'on peut trouver un hébergement je me
suis
donc là la régulation va appeler les
centres d'hébergement pour savoir si on
déplace le rappelle
c'est le centre de satory à versailles
qui accueillera ce monsieur pour cette
nuit les trois bénévoles l'y emmène mais
ne s'y attarde de contrat
oui bonsoir si l'asm saint quentin on
amène une personne pour
juste le temps de le déposer avant de
repartir pour un autre appel à montigny
le bretonneux cette fois ci c'est un
homme que michel connaît bien georges
fromentin vit dans la rue depuis sept
ans et pour lui l'aide de la croix rouge
est indispensable du jour là
on peut les appeler ou les appelle pas
ils veulent quand même moi j'ai connu à
l'hiver peine née quand je le mets à la
batte un gros temps
couvert de neige on croyait que j'étais
mort et moi j'ai pas froid j'avais
toujours
mal à gérer une couverture tournoi un
soutien matériel mais surtout un soutien
moral ces quelques minutes passées à
discuter avec les bénévoles autour d'une
soupe et d'un café chaud ils sont
extrêmement importantes
et on leur apporte une présence ou mort
quelquefois on est appelé simplement
pour parler
les gens refusent l'aide alimentaire les
couvertures ou une aide et festive en
terre sont parlés généralement pour un
café ensemble
georges refusera d'aller dans un centre
mais acceptera tout de même quelques
vêtements une poignée de main et un
sourire sincère pour remercier ses
bienfaiteurs anonymes il est 22h30
michel appelle à nouveau la régulation
pour eux la soirée loin d'être terminée
voilà pour ce sujet est signée mélanie
poker williams elle et puis sachez que
la croix-rouge recherche sans cesse des
bénévoles les fêtes de noël continue à
être organisée sur les communes de saint
quentin en yvelines ce week-end c'était
au tour de trappes de proposer des
animations pour ses habitants mélanie
bloqués
difficile de savoir où donner de la tête
ce samedi à la mairie de trappes sa
entrer ça sortait de l'hôtel de ville
dehors plus de 150 personnes attendaient
pour profiter de la patinoire on a voulu
aussi
spécifiquement
intégrer tout le monde dans cette fête
de fin d'année et donc la patinoire
c'est le moyen aussi d'avoir la jeunesse
pas la petite enfance qui est plutôt sur
le père noël et sur les axes et les
animations mais aussi des familles
patins chaussée gants filets c'était
parti pour la glisse pour ceux qui
parvenaient à rester debout mais pas de
quoi refroidir les zombies j'ai bien
patiné je me suis bien amusé et là
quelques-uns qui sont tombés mais s'il
est trop bien ses doigts initiative une
offre il ya pas mal de temps l'arrière
deux ans je vois quelque chose comme ça
et c'est vrai que en plus pour le coup
et pour le temps ben franchement c'est
très appréciable à l'intérieur de la
mairie même agitation activités
manuelles jeux de société séance photo
que le père noël maquillage il y en
avait pour tous les goûts mais parce
qu'il n'ya pas que les enfants qui ont
le droit de s'amuser et les parents
étaient aussi invités à créer c'est un
stand qui réservée cette fois ci pour
les adultes pour les mamans parce que
ben voilà on s'est dit il ya plein de
choses pour les enfants des adultes
aussi ont envie de participer donc en
fait là elles peuvent qu on fait qu'ils
peuvent confectionner ils voulaient
étoiles pour mettre dans le sapin de
noël etc pour leurs enfants au détour
d'un couloir on a même pu croiser deux
pingouins avec la magie de noël les
adultes deviennent aussi des enfants
alors sympathique les pingouins aimerait
bien savoir qui se cache derrière ces
masques à les installer au coeur du
quartier de porchefontaine à versailles
le chapiteau méli mélo est à la fois une
école de cirque un lieu de résidence
artistique est un lieu de diffusion du
spectacle vivant en cette période de
fêtes deux compagnons présenter
quelques-uns de leurs numéros de cirque
contemporain
de quoi donner un avant goût de leur
spectacle complet qui sera proposée qui
seront par nous proposer l'année
prochaine et lionel torrès elodie moines
on
de la musique quelques valises un peu
d'humour et beaucoup de talent ce sont
les ingrédients de la compagnie akiba
arrivé en résidence ici au chapiteau
méli mélo en 2006 ces artistes ont
proposé hier quelques-uns de leurs
numéros
nous on travaille beaucoup avec des
systèmes d'impro à 3 ans fait donc y en
a un qui donne une prime un peu une
impro et d'autres crimes on allait
dessus et c'est en même temps il ya un
côté très cirque traditionnel avec les
chevaux l'éléphant etc mais il ya une
espèce de passation de pouvoirs aussi
qui se fait donc on peut y voir aussi ça
en fait le fait de prendre le pouvoir
d'être autoritaire par rapport à l'autre
hier à cuba n'était pas la seule
compagnie en scène
marina et calmes ils se sont rencontrés
ici lors de leur entraînement en école
de cirque aujourd'hui elles forment la
mia compagnie mêlant cordes et mâts
chinois les deux circassienne se
rapproche par la musique hier elles ont
offert leur toute première
représentation est parti sur l'idée du
piano vous d'avoir de la musique live
marina il fait du piano et de la corde
et moi je fais du mât chinois
déséquilibrée de la clarinette et donc
on est parti de ce qu'on savait faire
après un spectacle autour de la musique
et des arts du cirque
venus nombreux grands parents et petits
enfants semblent conquis
nous avons tout aimé c'était formidable
j'étais surprise de la qualité vraiment
chapeau à cette extraordinaire j'aimais
bien la fille qui était en rouge qui
quand elle elle était sûre enfin quand
elle dansait avec le monsieur de quoi
encourager les artistes dont le
peaufinage de leur spectacle car ce
n'était là qu'un aperçu l'ania compagnie
présentera ses numéros complets en avril
les artistes d'akiba compagnie quant à
eux se préparent pour le mois de juin
prochain
on continue avec du sport
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a décidé de se concentrer
dorénavant sur le haut niveau contexte
économique oblige un recentrage a été
opéré la politique de subvention des
clubs sportifs va dorénavant donc se
concentrer sur les clubs évoluant à haut
niveau et sur les coques présentant un
intérêt communautaire fort une avance
sur subvention d'un montant global de
124 mille euros a été versée à 32 clubs
de l'agglomération lors du conseil
communautaire de jeudi dernier parmi les
plus forts bénéficiaires le à saint
quentin le triathlon club de saint
quentin en yvelines au club de tennis de
table d'élan cours ou encore les
templiers d'elancourt et puis maintenant
je vous propose un retour sur la coupe
de france de basket dans le 7-8 sport
d'hier lundi anthony rech recevait le
club de maurepas qui avait battu l'ogre
barjouville ans 128e de finale de la
coupe de france un vrai exploit pour le
club yvelinois et bien il faudra encore
réaliser un exploit pour les 64e de
finale de la coupe de france le tirage
au sort est tombé ce sera donc quand
caen leader de la poule de nationale 2
avec une seule défaite au compteur
depuis le début de saison qu'en basket
est une équipe composée notamment
d'anciens joueurs professionnels c'est
dire si en plus des quatre divisions
d'écart le challenge sera encore très
relevé pour le muhr pas y un recompte
prévu les 3 ou 4 janvier de la micro
chaîne télé fit évidemment sera bien
présent pour suivre la rencontre et
encourager les joueurs merci de votre
attention ce journal est terminée je
vous donne rendez-vous à demain pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 excellente
soirée à vous